I'm going to show you how to answer any
high-pressure question on the spot
without going blank. I'm talking about
when your boss puts you on the spot in
front of your team or when a client asks
you something you don't know the answer
to or even when you get asked an
interview question that catches you off
guard. As long as you follow these exact
three steps in this video, you'll never
go blank again. I've tested this process
in high-stakes meetings to stages of up
to 10,000 people and it works. So,
here's how to do it. The first thing I
would do
is I would pause
to collect my thoughts.
And I would give myself as long as of a
pause as I need so that I don't start to
freak out. The mental block happens when
you're trying to come up with an answer
in 1 second, in half a second, in a
millisecond. That's what causes the
panic, the anxiety, which is then going
to inevitably lead to a mental blank.
Whereas when you pause,
take a deep breath,
>> [sighs]
>> as you pause and take a deep breath,
that creates mental clarity.
That helps you calm your nervous system
down. And in that state, you are much
more likely to give yourself the best
chance to find a good response. People
tend to think that answering a question
quickly makes them look good, makes them
look smart. When you answer a question
really quickly, it doesn't do that. It
makes it seem as if you didn't put any
thought into the answer. Because if you
asked me a question and you said, "Hey
Vin, how do you answer a high-pressure
situation?" Oh, I can I don't know how
to do that. The first thing you're going
to do is you're just going to pause. And
then after you pause, you're going to
use a framework. And then after you use
a framework, you can deliver it
confidently. Most people just speak when
they're just winging things and they
think that's going to help them create a
really good career. That's why.
No, it doesn't. When you answer a
question without taking a moment to
think about what the person said,
it looks as if you don't care. When you
ask me this, if I paused
and then now I answer question. That's a
confident pause.
That's a pause of me processing what
you're saying, carefully considering
what I'm going to say next, and then
sharing my thoughts. Now, there's a few
key things I want to say here. If you
look to the side and you think, and you
raise a hand up and you start to think
about something like this, or you go
into the thinker pose and you start to
think,
this is a powerful pose to move into
because it shows people now I'm
processing.
Now, that's a good pause. However, if
you pause and then you you you slouch
and then you look down, and then you're
you're fidgeting with your hands, that's
a negative pause because they'll
perceive that pause as you being
anxious, and you not knowing the answer.
So, there's two different types of
pauses. One where I'm freaking out and I
don't know the answer and you caught me
out. One where I'm being really composed
and I'm
I'm thinking about how to answer this in
a way that adds the most value to you.
So, just notice that within body
language cues alone plays a very
important part in that. The second thing
that I would say is if you pause for a
good two to three seconds,
and you can't in that moment think about
the optimum reply,
then be straightforward with the person
that's in front of you. Say they asked
you a question about marketing. So, I'm
going to create a mock scenario. Then,
how should I use marketing, organic
marketing, to get more leads for the
business that I'm running?
Emily, I'd love to share with you a
thoughtful answer.
Let me ask you this. Would it be helpful
if I met with you later today, and I'll
give you a comprehensive answer because
I've been through content creation for
the last 15 years of my life, and I want
to give you the most meaningful answer.
So, I want a little more time to think
on that. Is that okay for me to take a
bit more time to think on it and and
give you the most valuable answer
possible later today?
Fantastic. I'll I'll set up a time.
Let's Why don't we set up a time so I
can think about it over lunch, and I'll
share with you the experience that I
have.
But, something like that is fine. It's
totally fine. I think we panic because
we think
we have to prove ourselves by answering
them in the moment off the cuff straight
away.
People don't want to rush to answer.
They want an answer that adds the most
value to their lives and people are
willing to wait for that. The next thing
I'm going to say is that what increases
your chances of being able to answer on
the spot is I would use a framework.
Because when someone asks you, "Vin, can
you teach us how to create organic
content that creates leads?" Let's say
that's the example.
My brain now is freaking out because
there are so many different things you
can do for content creation that helps
generate leads, for example. My brain's
going crazy because I'm I'm thinking
about all the different things that you
can do.
Whereas when you use the framework, the
one thing, so I'll show you this in
action. Someone asks you a question,
"Hey Vin, what's something that I can do
when it comes to content creation to get
more leads organically?"
Listen, the one thing I would say about
content creation, whether it's for lead
generation or
views or building the number of
followers, the one thing that I'd say is
consistency. Consistency is the most
important thing.
That's the most important strategy that
I've discovered as the universal truth.
To become better at generating more
content and generating more leads, just
keep creating content. And as you create
content, you'll get better and better
and better through consistency and
you'll learn how to get more views and
then you'll learn how to get more leads.
But the underlying foundation is
consistency.
I'm able to deliver that and I use the
sentence the one thing.
Now, the most beautiful thing about this
is that I'm not saying that that that is
everything to do with content creation.
I'm saying that that if there was one
thing to focus on, that's what I'd focus
on. And if you haven't been through a
framework class with me, I put together
a free 2-hour crash course where I share
three powerful communication frameworks
to help you improve the way you speak
while you're under pressure so that you
can come across more clear, concise, and
coherent in any situation. Just click
the link in the description or you can
scan the QR code that's on screen.
Again, it's completely free and
thousands of people have been through
it, so go check it out. And by doing
this, I now have given myself time to
think more on this topic, talk on the
topic in a focused way. So, I've talked
about consistency, but what you've done
there is you've bought yourself time to
better answer their question in the most
valuable way possible. The third thing
you do at the end of you using the
framework The One Thing, the third thing
you do is you ask
a question.
And the question you ask right at the
end is, once again, depending on the
context, is did you want me to go deeper
on that topic? Did you want to get more
granular in terms of the strategy? I can
look at their facial expressions. If
they're smiling and nodding, that's what
they're after. And at the end, I check
in. Do you want more? Do you want me to
go deeper on this? Do you want to go
into pragmatic strategies on how to
create hooks and bodies and CTAs, call
to actions, etc.? Do you want me to do
that?
And they might say yes. And if they say
yes, then you go down deeper in the
rabbit hole. The danger in not using
frameworks and answering questions on
the spot is you end up speaking out your
thought process. This is scientifically
how your thinking process looks.
Yeah, this is a scientific diagram that
I'm drawing.
And when someone asks you something
about content creation, and you don't
follow a framework, your brain starts to
go, "Oh, oh, of course I can tell you
about content creation and doing things
organically. You know, the first thing
you got to understand from a
foundational level is you got to be
consistent. The second thing I got to
tell you about, too, is that you got to
write a really good hook. A lot of
people have a really good body And then
you're just blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah. No matter how valuable
what you're saying is, the value is lost
in you rambling. So, what a framework
does,
a framework distills your thinking.
That's what it does.
This distillation process here,
that process right here,
that's what frameworks do.
Because it simply distills your thinking
into something that is more concise,
more coherent, and it's going to be more
credible as you communicate to that
point in that concise way. Pause.
Once you learn the frameworks,
pick a framework, share just one thought
about that topic, ask a question, do you
want to go deeper?
That's the best way for you to navigate
that situation.